In this video, we'll be completing our one
piece mitered neck band for a square neck
line.
We've used centered double decreases
to shape the public side of the band.
Now we want to finish the
inside or the facing side.
We'll be using short row increases
to create little corners.
Let's try a practice piece first.
Cast on 50 stitches or
so and knit a few rows.
Hang weights if you need to.
Let's pretend that these two needles
represent our miter stitches from the
front side of the band.
Mark the needle bed
for these two stitches.
We'll work one corner at a time.
Identify the left miters stitch and three
stitches on each side for a total of seven
stitches.
Okay.
Initially, we'll only be knitting
over these seven stitches.
The carriage is on the right, put all
of the needles to the left of our seven
corner stitches into hold position
and set the carriage to hold.
Knit across.
prevent a hole by wrapping the
first needle in hold position.
Now isolate those same seven corner
stitches by putting all of the needles to
the right of these corner stitches into
hold position and knit across those
corners stitches only.
Workthe short row increases by putting one
needle next to the carriage and to hold
position and knit across.
One needle next to the carriage and
to hold position and knit across.
Continue until there's
only one needle left.
Can you see, by isolating those seven
stitches, we've created a point?
Let's knit the other corner point.
I don't want to break my yarn, so I will
manipulate the carriage and the needles
inwork until I can isolate the
next set of corner stitches.
Knit across the single stitch that's in
work, positioning the carriage on the
left.
Identify the next set of corner stitches
and put them into working position.
Plus put the center needles
into working position.
These are the needles between
the two corners and knit across.
With the carriage on the right.
We can now isolate the next set of corner
stitches by putting the needles to the
left of them into hold position.
Remember all we want to knit for right now
are those seven little corner stitches.
We had to work the last couple steps to
get the working yarn into the correct
place to start knitting
those isolated stitches.
Work your short row
increases on this corner.
Just like before, put one
stitch on each side into hold
until you're down to the one stitch.
To finish the row, put the needles to the
right of the corner into work and knit.
Then put all of the stitches into working
position and knit across from right to
left.
Bind off all the stitches
for our little sample.
And you should have a piece
that looks something like this.
These points will fill
in the band corners.
Next watch as we work these short row
increases creating points on a mitered
band.
You're now ready to knit the band facing.
If you knit straight up from here, you'll
have a total of 24 fewer stitches than
when you originally picked up the band.
You can fudge and just stitch the
facingdown, but doing a few short rows on
the facing, we'll give you squared
corners to completely encase the band.
Start by identifying the six stitches on
either side of the miter stitch on the
left side of the bed.
Set your machine to hold and
pullout to holding position.
All the stitches to the
right of these six stitches.
You'll be knitting the left neckline
stitches and the six mitered stitches.
The center front and the right neck line
stitches are in hold.
Knit across and wrap the
first needle in hold.
Now put into holding position all of
the needles to the left of the six miter
stitches.
You'll be short rowing on just these six
stitches knit across, put the first stitch
on the carriageside into hold.
Knit across. Add a weight to
make the knitting easier.
Put the first stitch on
the carriage side to hold.
Repeat until there is
only one stitch left.
Now identify the six mitered stitches
on the right side of the bed.
Pull all of the stitches
on the right into work.
The center front, the right neck, opening
stitches, leaving the left neck, opening
stitches in hold.Knit one row to the right.
With the carriage on the right.
Put the center stitches back into hold.
Knit to the left, wrap the first
needle on the carriage side.
Put the remaining stitches
in hold and leave.
Only the six mitered stitches in work.
Work your short rows asbefore until one
stitch is in work with the carriage on the
left.
Place all the stitches to the right
of the single stitch back into work.
Knit across.
Set the carriage to knit all
stitches and knit one row.
Now bind off..
The band facing is shaped to fit the
band whip stitch the phasing down neatly.
Here's an option.
Instead of binding off the facing, remove
the piece on waste yarn, stitch it down,
catching each live stitch.
The top image here shows this flat and
neat finish written instructions for this
technique are included with this video
on KnititNow.com Enjoy your mitered bands.